two family house my mother's sister
lives downstairs with the upstairs
apartment so even in those days I used
to stay up late cuz I I didn't have
patience to go to sleep and wait for the
sleep to come like I really had to be
tired you know yeah that I'm like that
to this day I wait for sleep like come
on already where are you so um yeah like
I don't believe in just I I can't even
believe it when somebody could just lay
down and they're out like you well then
don't lay down till you're tired no yeah
4 in the morning yeah still all good
yeah I love staying up late but my
girlfriend right yeah it I could be
watching TV she come out she go um how
late you going to St aren't you going to
go to bed I'm like I'm allowed to I'm a
man like if I want to stay up and make
some phone calls what do you care you
know I make calls all night all night
yeah late yeah who do people appreciate
that just friends of M friends that's
stay up late you know that kind of stuff
do you think they're staying up late
because they L to stay up you know it's
that's what the part of show business I
love stay up late yeah I love that I
love working out late I love talking on
the phone late I love that stuff so but
she'll be like it's time to go to bed I
go what okay Mom you know like what time
do she go to oh well now it's late you
know you now it's like now it's like 1
clock is big for her really you know
yeah she she'll be like I go to bed
before 9: yeah but you you do you have
like network shows you you have a
different lifestyle apparently I have
patience you know no I 9:00 at night I'm
first eating dinner at 9 or 10 really
yeah I love being up late I love you're
you're in middle school and you're
impatiently waiting for sleep